All right, here we go. Three hot mics, a good guest I'm thinking, I'm hoping. Sean, when was the last time you had three hot mics? That was like in my early 20s, my early 20s. Yeah, yeah. And by the way, it was confusing. We didn't know which end was it. I'm bad.
None of them wanted to be called Michael. No, Mike, Mike, Mike. All right. And they were all equally hot? They were all equally hot. OK. Well, welcome to Smartless. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. That was fun that we got to see each other today. I know, just a half an hour ago.
In person. Yeah, listen very rarely. Well, the three of us actually see each other in person before we start doing this. And we didn't we didn't we didn't expend any magic that that we would have left for the show. Yeah, we said we have to cry. No, the magic got stayed for sure. I gotta say Jason was not feeling well and he was on the other side of the table. It was big conference room and I got home. I got a little tickle on
my throat. You do not. I don't know. It's your head. Well, really. My virus has great reach on it. Did it? Well, I don't know. But Jay, that was so, like Wilson, that was so nice of you if you're feeling sick to go to the party on Saturday too. Yeah, that was nice of you. Well, but I didn't really feel it just yet.
I wasn't really sure, you know. I would have never known you were in a good mood and lovely on Saturday. Just into this game. He did this game. Working. I was standing outside Sean, he did this game. Working. I was standing outside Sean, did you just left? We didn't see each other, but Jason came out
and he was holding two cupcakes. One was the big normal size one, one was the tiny baby one. Today, when we just left? No, no, no, the party on Saturday. And so he's got these cupcakes and he's doing a whole dance with it. And he's like eating the little one
and then somebody said to him, why did you have, well, I'm just gonna eat the little one, and I just got this one. So we continue to talk, and he put the big one, normal one down. And he eventually, well, he, first of all, I was like, if you've seen this before,
and he took the top off, and he turned it upside down and ate it like a sandwich, so that you always get a nice invite. But then he put it down, and then this person said that, put it down, and then he put it a little further away. But then he put it down, and then this person said that, put it down, then he put it a little further away. And then he just went over and he walked it over to another table.
Is that right, Jamie? Because you were like, it's too tempting close to you. You don't wanna have a grenade near you. Wait, I did not know that there was cupcakes there. Yeah, well, that was not the plot. That's why I don't know. Fuck me, man.
Well, first of all, you drifted over, you know, I gave everyone a very useful lesson as to how to eat a cupcake, which a lot of people don't know. I didn't know that. You twist off the top, you flip it over, you make it a sandwich, and then you don't get frosting up your nose.
That's A, B. The reason you don't know there were cupcakes there, Sean, is because you always do. Yeah. Very rudely. do. Very rudely. Very rudely. Because you're the first one at a party so that you can say you were there and that you can't get yelled at when you leave early because you've put in a bunch of time and you get your food and then you pack up your shit and you leave. It is true. It is true. Anyone who has shown us the amount of you. And I'm like, I wanna go home yet. Everybody does, man. I do wanna go. I want to go to a birthday cake that came out later
and some singing. So why did you leave? Why did you go in now? Why did you go at seven when it started and then leave so early? Me and Richard were there and Jenny were there. Richard and I. Tricky Dickie. Richard and I.
And first, and no, I enjoy going to those things. I was happy to go. I just, you know, I don't have a long fuse for parties. I'm the one with short fuse because I can't get into my cups like everyone else. And you start laughing at shit that doesn't deserve to be even smiled at. Did you have the chili?
I had the chili with me. Yeah, the chili. I had the chili at the time when everyone else had it. Not really. Where did you get the cupcakes? JB goes, JB goes to one point. Winston and Sadden and he goes, I gotta get out of here.
And he said, he's like, said like three times I said, where are you going? And he goes, I gotta gummy and a Lakers game to get into him. And that late at night on a Saturday. He was tape. You know, I mean, I type record again.
Jason's beard and hair is growing so gloriously long. It's crazy. I know. It was the talk of the party. No. Yeah, it was. It looks good. What, how I can't really grow facial hair? No, you look good. No, it looks good like that. Yeah, shut up. It looks good. What do you see it in three more months when it looks really bad? No, thank you. No, I...
Well, not no, thank you, but also I doubt it. I think it looks really good. Whose guest is it today? It's my guest and guess what? What? You're gonna be real psyched. Hey, guest what? Guest what? Sean.
Thank you. It's true, you guys are gonna be, you guys are gonna be, let us guess. We've never really really guessed. Okay, so male or female? No, guess. You ever wanted to be a big, like, you know what, you're gonna narrow it down by getting it.
Five guesses to nail it down, but narrower. Male, okay. Actor. Yes. Older or younger than us? Younger, decidedly. Well, okay, decidedly, but yeah, more than two. This is a person who is a, America.
He has to get ready for this. His awards, his awards nominations has its own Wikipedia page. Really? And this is, okay, this is mostly film or television or music. Mostly film, some television back in the, but mostly film. I mean, two Academy Award nominations, two BAFTAs, four Emmys. Is this for some British? No, American, three globes, five sag award nominations, Tony Award nomination, critics choice up the wazoo, every critic. You're nervous now, God. You know what, here I'll give you a list of the names
of all the directors this guy's worked with. You ready for this? Tell me if you like any of these names. Ridley Scott, Terry. Terry Gilliam. Steven Soderbergh, Martin Scorsese Z. That's Russell. Who, JJ Abrams. Did I just guess it right?
No, Noah Bomback. Adam Driver? Sean Levy. Yeah, it's Adam Driver. Did I get him? No way! I got Adam on out. That's my brother.
That's my sweet brother. That's why I said you're gonna be saying. You guys know each other? Yeah. We worked on a project together. Adam, you were awesome on Sarenite Live. Oh, amazing. I just watched you do it.
Hey, show your recall. Thank you. It's terrible. The beat beat. Yeah, it's just like when you get a real actor in there doing Sarenite Live when you get a real actor in there doing Saturday Night Live, every sketch works, you know, this guy's making choices. Yeah, and I know that you didn't get a Saturday Night Live. I don't know, I think he's just
sensitive to the material and he's a funny dude, obviously. Well, I make a choice. It's a good choice. I've seen some good actors fucking bomb on SNL, let's be honest. Yeah, that's true. But he's just got Adam, you were so good, you were so funny. You're timing is so fucking good, dude. We are getting this episode, but all good. What about the piano playing? That seemed very weird. I know, I was blown away.
Yeah, it was real. Is that you? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's amazing. Oh my God, I'd love to see a piano off between you. That's what that's a term, right? A piano off between you and Sean. I don't know if they use that. I'd lose. Yeah, that's amazing. Oh my God, I'd love to see a piano off between you. That's what that's a term, right? A piano off between you and Sean. I don't know if they use that. I'd lose.
Yeah, that's a term. I lose. Adam, tell me about that. How long did you play piano? Did you study? Well, I played with, I played for, since I was a kid, but my mom tried to teach me, so it wasn't very, I didn't stick to it.
I feel like you're supposed to. You can cancel one, right? You're not, you're not supposed to, right? You're not supposed to have a parent teach you how to play piano because you never actually stick with it. Yeah. So that's true. That's why I dropped it.
You said the, you know, my parents, my parents thought they were being real crafty when I said, I don't want to play. I hate, I hate practicing. You're going to practice. They would make me and you have the same material for a week, right? Because you have a, you have lessons once a week. And so they would say, you're going to, we're going to find out whether you're practicing or not, you're going to record your lesson or, right? Because you have lessons once a week. And so they would say, you're gonna find out whether you're practicing
or not you're gonna record your lesson, or sorry, you're gonna record your practice and we're gonna play it one week at home from work. And so I just record it once on the Monday and then just playing the same tape all week. And like they never figured it out. It was a lot of progress, really. I don't really know the Sunday, but yeah, but yeah, that was that
was it. They weren't bright, but they were strict. And you've always been such a fucking shit. Yeah, no, you've just a little shit since they were fucking bored. Not about me, though. Let's talk to Adam Adam driver, dude, dude, I'm so stoked to have you on here. I just, I just think you're so, you're just such a talent to dude. Everything you do is so fucking great. Thank you. Yeah, man. And then when I start to find out when I like looking back and, you know, looking about your sort of your background, I mean, you didn't, this seems to me and tell me it from wrong. You're from Southern California, right? Is that where you raised in Southern California? I raised in Indiana.
I lived in San Diego. Yeah, until I was seven. Okay, so until you were seven, you raised in Indiana. So you raised in Indiana, then 9-11 hits, you joined the military, right? You go into the Marines and I know you've talked about it before, but you go in, but it just seems like you had to kind of go a long way to get, but you knew what you wanted to do. Like you wanted to go to Julia Hard, the first time when you were seven, teen is that right?
Yeah. And then you ended up going later, like walk me through, I just, what I'm sort of driving at is, you will get to time, you know, I swear. I'm fine, I could just listen to you guys. sort of driving at is you will get to time and I swear. No, he's getting ready. I'm fine, I could just listen to you guys. You're just a dude who is destined to do, like you knew what you wanted to do and it was fucking, you were just gonna get there
no matter what. Kind of, I did plays in high school and then I auditioned for Juilliard because they didn't check grades. That was the prerogative of colleges that I was going to. And I knew that the Julia had had reputation of being the best of acting school for theater. And then I didn't get in. And then 9-11 happened. And I feel like a lot of people, a lot of friends in Indiana all thought they were going to join. But then none of them did. And then I was the only one
that did. Kind of like we all got riled up. And then I was the only one that did. Kind of like, we all got riled up. And then I was the only one that actually walked through the door. And then it was until I was in the military, really, that I'm like, oh, if I get, you know, if I get to be a civilian again, or when I get to be a civilian again, I knew I wanted to go back and try, try again to be a civilian again. I knew I wanted to go back and try again to be an actor. Was that a, was that a foreign question, by the way, how deep did you get into your military exploits? I loved it. The whole plan when I was in the military is to make a career of it. It was the retire, you know, in the Marine Corps. Oh, really? Yeah. And then it was only because I had a mountain biking accident.
I broke my sternum that I tried to train on it so I could still go overseas because all of the guys that I went to boot camp and then SOI then went into the fleet with, you know, it was all the same kind of core group of people. And then they were all going to go do a Westpac of Iraq and Afghanistan and again, I was kind of trying to train on a broken sternum so I could go go with them. And I got dropped to a different unit and all my friends went. And so I was not it was not good. Then 9-11 or you wanted to do it anyway? It was kind of twofold. It was a response to 9-11, but also I wasn't doing anything.
I was working jobs. I had two telemarketing jobs and I was working at a... I'd love to hear a little bit of that script. One was for a basement waterproofing company called Ben Franklin Construction. You probably... I don't... And then the other one was, uh... Are things smelling dank downstairs? Don't hang on. I, I used to have to read that same script for a different business.
Really? For a different business. Sure, sure. I got no sleep noises. So, he was like, he was glad. But that, that was kind of it. And I, I, I got something in the mail and my stepdad, and I were having an argument about me being a loser and not having any jobs.
And he kind of like, off-handedly said, maybe you should join the military. And again, it was in the same time of everyone kind of being like, well, we want to get involved and do something. So it kind of all kind of coalesced. And I think I made the decision by January and by February I was gone.
So much so that they were like, are you on the run from the law? Because you've made people go, you're very eager, Mr. Driver. Wow, how's your relationship with your stepdad now? That's good. It's surprising. He's good.
Yeah, is he proud of you? Yeah. I guess you won the question of whether or not you were a loser. You got to, you over it. Not only am I going to join the military, but I'm going to go through Booth, can I become a Marine, and then I'm going to kick ass in the completely opposite end of the world as well. Yeah, and become a fucking movie star.
I mean, it's pretty remarkable. So you come back from serving, you leave the military, or you get discharged, as you said, and then you're like, what, back at square one, you're like, how do you climb the mountain that you've climbed? Like, what was... You reapplied at Juilliard, yeah. I reapplied at Juilliard. Actually, I should say before I left for the military,
I tried coming to LA and doing the whole acting thing. And I totally failed. I had a Lincoln town car, and I was paying rent in the back of my parent's house. And I loaded up this massive car, and I drove across country to California, and I broke down in Amarillo, Texas, and wound up spending all my money fixing my car.
So by the time I got to Santa Monica, not even LA, I was here for 48 hours before I turned right and drive right back. He wasn't having any more money. I had no money to stay. I drove out to Chicago and my car broke down in Colorado, like around a mountain, and I was dragging the muffler for the last part. And I had a pullover, it cost me a thousand bucks, but I made it.
Oh, really? Yeah, same. I looked at my car, it was outside of Amarillo, Texas, and I got a hitch to ride into town, and then took my car and got a fix. But that was all my money. I had just 200 bucks left, which I knew from having just made the trip was enough gas money to get home.
And I made a whole production about saying goodbye to everybody back in New York. Sure. Then 40 out of your back. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I can't believe that. But you know, Adam, a lot of people would, after an experience like that,
which is, I mean, that's not traumatizing, but it's a lot. Like you go through, you make the, like you said, you make a big production out of, I'll see you guys later, you give your farewell to the troupe, as it were, and then a week later, you're back or less.
And then you go, and then you go into the military. A lot of people would be like, you know what? The universe was trying to tell me something, or it's, it's a lot to pick yourself up again and to go, no, I wanna fucking do this. This is kinda what I'm getting out of the beginning, which is like, you're just like, no, you're determined. You knew that you had a purpose in this world, especially doing this.
Not really. No, I still didn't want to. The idea of being an actor was like being an astronaut. I had no connections to anybody in the acting world and in the small town in Indiana. So I just kind of put that idea to bed. I still liked movies. to anybody in the acting world and in the small town in Indiana. So I just kind of put that idea to bed. I still liked movies. But I just kind of gave up on that.
And then when the Marine Corps came along, I fully threw myself at that. And it was only during the military where I felt like, well, in comparison to the Marine Corps civilian life, I think, should be pretty easy. I knew that New York was kind of what I wanted to do if I ever got out and having, you know, I could sleep in the Central Park. I felt more confident that I could be an adult and survive. How did you know you were any good at acting? I found in high school the response I got from people was positive, you know, but it's an high school in Indiana. I didn't really know until I auditioned for
Juilliard the second time and I got out. So, right, so how did that happen? So you get out of the military, how do you auditioned the second time? Like, what was that process like? So, I got out and I went to a school called University of Indianapolis and then I start getting parts and plays right away. And I knew that the audition date for Juilliard was they had three days, four days in New York, they don't do this now, but they do four days in New York, four days in Chicago and four days in LA. And I knew they were auditioning in Chicago in February, so I drove up and I stayed the night and I auditioned in Chicago. And then, yeah, then I found out I
got in like a two months, two months later. Did you find like, did you enjoy your time in the Marine Court and why you were there? Were you thinking about acting the whole time? No, I enjoyed it until a point. And then I really, because I was on the verge of being separated, all my guys kind of left of left, that I, you know, they're like, okay, then maybe I shouldn't, this, I'm not long for this.
Yeah, that's weird, because the whole time Sean's acting, he's thinking about Marines. So listen. I can get in Yang thing. I mean, I got it, I get it, Adam. So you can, so you see, you go fucking Chicago, it blows me away, man. I get it. So you come, so you see, go fucking Chicago.
It blows me away, man. I just, it's just like, not long shot because you're down, I was in mega town to do, but you go in your audition and then two months later you find out, it's your fucking dream. What's your reaction when you find out you're getting to Juilliard? Like, yeah, it was beyond.
I was working full-time at a Target distribution warehouse and going to school full-time at University of Indianapolis, so it was kind of pulling all nighters and then going to school full-time. So I was beyond, you know, you're like screaming all the... It must have felt like getting like this is your chance, you're going to get pulled into this out of your world and into this other world that you've been trying to get into and you've been dreaming of. This is about to happen, it must have felt like that.
But I wasn't even thinking of like, oh, now I'm gonna be an actor and plays or now I'm gonna be in film. So just the idea of going to New York was another. And the alumni of Juilliard, I was very aware of, And the alumni of Juilliard, I was very aware of. And how it's a conservatory and it was a great place to put a lot of energy. You know, it was in the early 20s.
So. Did you have a good idea of what, what, what, I mean, obviously you got a very good idea of what it would be like to live in New York. We all see it in TV and movies and whatnot. But Juilliard itself, did you have a pretty decent idea of what that experience was going to be like and if so, did it match with that idea? Once you got that. No frame of reference for what living in New York would be, well, other than films that,
but no frame of reference of like an acting conservatory. A lot of the kids in my class were four years younger than I was and kind of had gone to performing arts schools or they were there for their graduate degree. They don't do this anymore. Even if you went to an undergrad program, you would get your diploma, but now it's a graduate program also. But so people had come from performing arts backgrounds.
And I didn't. So when I moved to the city, like summer before I started, and we'll go to the performing arts library and try to read plays that everybody knew that I didn't know, like a Tony Kushner plays. That's so cool. David Mamma plays, and I've watched the performances and the video library to get Lincoln at Lincoln Center. Yeah, yeah, that's so cool. You know, I know you did burn this in 2019. Yeah, yeah. I did that in college, of course.
I played Larry. He played Payal, of course. We would have been a brilliant match to him. You would have been great. But a friend of mine was in the play. And they didn't, and on the huge marquee downtown LA, he did burn this. And they didn't separate the letter.
So it looked like burnt his. And so that's that's what we referred to. That's LA Theater for you. That's LA Theater. Yeah. And we will be right back. Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of SmartLess. The NFL regular season is wrapping up, but there's still time to get in on the action
with FanDuel, America's number one sports book. Right now, new customers get 150 in bonus bets guaranteed when you place a $5 bet. That's 150 bucks in bonus bets, win or lose. The app is so easy to use and there are so many different ways to bet, like live same game parlays, find bets in the new Explore tab, make a parlay in the parlay hub, the best way to find popular parlays and more. You know what'd be fun to bet on? How many pigs in a blanket I can eat in, like, say, 30 minutes?
Who's in for that? Who would bet on that? I'd probably throw up after three, but maybe more, but that's what you'd be betting on. So visit fandool.com slash smartless and make your first bet a layup, fandool, official partner of the NFL, 21 plus exclusions apply,
see show notes for Full Disclaimer. Thank you NBC for supporting this episode of The Show. Hey, happy new year everyone, and I've got a resolution for you. Laugh more. Good one, right? And to that end, I give you two hilarious comedies, starring two legendary Johns, John Lerocat in the new season of Nightcourt and John Cryer in his new comedy Extended Family. Tuesday nights and NBC, the laps are never in short order.
When New York's most outrageous court gets back in session, it's America's number one comedy Nightcourt, starring John Lerocat. And after that, catch John Cryer in a great new comedy about life and family after divorce, its Extended Family. Also starring the amazing Donald Fazon and Abigail Spencer. New Year's resolution, laugh more in 2024,
with help from two fantastic comedies, Nightcourt and extended family, starring John Lerocat and John Cryer. Tuesday's an NBC beginning January 2nd. ["The New Year's Day"] Hey, Smartless Crew, I've been drinking A.G.1 since 2020. It's become my daily go-to foundational nutrition, supplemented, it's true.
I trust AG1 because it's not just about what's in it, but what's not in it. AG1 is rigorously tested for 950 impurities way beyond the industry norm. Seriously, it's a game changer for me. I feel the difference daily. I have improved energy. It's so convenient.
I love the convenience of it. And I can do it at home or I can take the travel packs which is super convenient, you know, if I'm on the road. Now, let's get into the good stuff. Why AG1? It's a powerhouse for major body systems
with ingredients like vitamin C and zinc, which helps me keep my immune health in tip-top shape. And everybody at SmartList loves it too. They drink it religiously. AG1 is the supplement I trust to provide the support my body needs daily, and that's why they've been a partner for so long.
If you take just one thing, let it be AG1. Try AG1 and get a free one-year supply of vitamin D3K2 and 5 free AG1 travel packs with your first purchase. Go to drinkag1.com slash smartless so they know we sent you. That's drinkag1.com slash smartless. Check it out. So they know we sent you. That's drinkag1.com slash smartless. Check it out. All right, back to the show.
Now Adam, I don't, I've never met you in a huge fan. I'm like, trying to get the bit to ask you about Star Wars, which I'm sure you're sick of talking about. Cool it. But I know I'm a click. But I'm a huge fan. So we apologize. But you do seem like not knowing you at all. You seem to be a very kind, sweet, down to earth,
intelligent, yet introverted person. And so what is it like doing something like Saturday Night Live, which is the opposite of being introverted? And it's just going balls out. Like, is it scary? And is that why you wanted to do it? Or is it just another job?
I don't know why, it's kind of theater, I mean, in a way. So that's what I at least try to remind my, but it's terrifying. Yeah, it is. But I enjoy the, I would feel like theater on film. I like those old school plays on tape that they used to do live, Richard Burton, you know, doing Camelot.
And that's the only modern day equivalent of a show that does that. And I really enjoy the pressure. I don't know. It's a massive, but I'm also in my best behavior and things like this and in public. The real ego maniacal asshole is just waiting to come out all the time. We can't wait to meet him. Yeah, and a few weeks to hear that. There's no place.
You did, you did, you did seem beautifully relaxed. Yeah, well, I mean, there was an energy there for sure, but you certainly weren't terrified. It was pretty cool. Yeah, the last, I mean, the first time I did it, I thought I was gonna pass out when you walk out. But this time, I felt at ease. And I enjoy the pressure and I like it when there's a lot to do. You know, when the pressure's on,
and there's a lot of text and a lot of moving pieces and a lot of things falling apart, I actually kind of enjoy it. It reminds me of theater. I noticed you're not really reading the cards that much either. Did you try to commit certain lines to notice that? Yeah, I noticed that. So you could perform them well. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, because I don't like it usually when you can kind of tell that someone's reading
the cards and it kind of destroys the illusion. And when they're well written, it's easy to memorize. So some of it is, it's not that difficult. They hate it when you don't read the cards and it kind of destroys the illusion. And when they're well written, it's easy to memorize. So some of it is, it's not that difficult. They hate it when you don't read the cards though. Yeah, they're nervous. Is there one sketch that you particularly loved doing last time? There's one that I really liked that was cut. It was this one called court case. And it was this three-page speech that's not funny at all. And it only works if it's played as if it's absolutely serious. And we cut it. But then they released it online afterwards.
But I love that at the dress, everyone. I love the dead air and how awkward it was in the office. I love the... Are they doing that now? Are they putting the dress? Leasing cuts, the dress? Yeah, or some of it? Some of it. I love that. Are they doing that now? Are they are they releasing cuts sketch address? Yeah, some of it. Some of it. They that's cool with those. They they was two of them that they released this like court case one
and this one called actors journey. Because Tracy dresses short for dress. That's such a cool. That's a cool idea. Yeah. So right for Tracy, let her know that at they do dress rehearsal earlier on the on Saturday night, full. It's like a full performance of the show with some additional sketches and they cut a couple sketches before the live show.
Dress usually is over by about 10, 10, 30. And then the live show is 11, 30. But I think that's cool because there have been so many great sketches over the years that were cut after dress for various reasons and not always because they didn't work just because Sometimes political it's they also don't like the term skit either it's sketch right yeah, yeah, never Never say skit I like it. I like Lauren. I like the
Yeah, if you if you're feels like a you know, yeah, you're very comfortable in it You're so great at comedy too. Yeah, you're really good at it. Do you have, do you have, you're not a strategic guy, you're so beautifully down to earth with your career, it seems, but do you ask your people to look for comedy versus drama and try to keep a balance there? Or is this kind of like the best grip wins. Yeah, lately now, because I'm trying to change, because I was working consistently,
basically all through my 30s and now that I have two kids, I've been trying to switch of how I've been working, you know, where I'm, now I'm just like I can't be gone that long and I don't want to be gone that long anymore. So I'm trying to, I'm trying to probably like every game the system and for me the only way is now is trying to work on things from the beginning. If, you know, if I can, but I'm not against it to just whatever, no one's really asked me to do something like that or and I haven't found anything that I really, you know, wanted to do. But if something came along, I would totally do it. But you know, it's sort of like wake up at the middle of the night and stare at the ceiling and go like, I need to do a comedy.
You know, I'd like to, but I also don't want it to be bad, you know, so I would, you know, the Albert Brooks, to me, is like, you know, the top. Now, there's not a lot of people that are writing like that and you really gotta find them. And yeah, they're tough to find. How old are your kids? Eight months is my youngest in six is one, my other one, so six.
My kids are five years apart. All right. Do you, Is that good? It's yeah, I mean, it's it's good because one gets to help you take care of the other or the ones they think they are. But then like, you know, hanging out, you know, at a certain age is like, it's not, you know, when they, what do they know? Seventeen and twelve. It's, you know, like, they're going to be closer when they get older. But they're, they're, they're, there are times when that five year gap is not worse. Although, Jay, maybe I will say one of the nice things I've seen a couple times is your
17 year old dropping your 12 year old at school because they got the same school. That's pretty funny watching. Freddie drop maple was one of the funniest fucking things. That's funny. Yeah, I don't like it. I miss it. How are you liking dad stuff? I love it like it. I miss it. How are you liking dad stuff? I love it.
Yeah. Yeah. What you're describing as science fiction to me, the idea that one kid will... Even now, he is very protective over her. And I feel like we gave him, you know, six years of attention and he's totally fine, you know. And if you're like me, you missed, you missed changing diapers, you missed swaddling, you missed like, I was so excited to get to do it again.
Oh, I am nice. I know. No. No. This time I'm like, oh, we forgot how much baby's suck. You know, they don't, they don't tell you anything. They get to runny noses and it just destroys the next three days and they have sleep regressions and they're a teething. It's a, I mean, I am more aware this time that I'm like, oh, this is finite.
I have to remember this because it's gonna go away quickly. We're the first time I wasn't, I was so anxious for him to get older that I wasn't. And also the first time you're, and also the first time you're not, because you've never done it, you're like, is this normal? Should he be sick this much?
Should he be, should he be not eating, he hasn't eaten for two days. Jesus fucking you end up having those. We have a three and a half year old and we've just kind of just emerging from it again after my older kids are teenagers. And I'm like, fuck man, I just forgot exactly what you're talking about.
Just forgot all that shit waking up in the night. All the fucking life. Right, and they're durable. I mean, the first one you don't realize how durable they are in the second one. Yeah, I think it's fun. She's fine. She's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, for soakins. I just want to, well, let's talk about how you diaper your dog. Sean, real quick. No, I just, I just want to get through it. So you guys don't have enough. Again, and then we can go by.
Do you want to call Scotty in here? I mean, I did I just I texted him and he said yeah, he said he wrote it's well, he everybody knows it's no secret that me and Scotty are the sky. Sean's husband Scotty is like they the two of them are like the massive Adam might not be up on you. Scotty's you know that's okay I'm saying that's I'm telling Now everybody who listens is listening so Adam when you again, that's like 25 people here we go
question please 25 or so I have the obvious stock stock questions which is is it real? Please don't tell me it's not real. Yeah. Please tell me it's all freaking totally real. Totally real. I'm there now. Oh God. I'm there now. No, I want to know like, were you a fan before? What was it like getting, you know, getting like getting that call to be like, you're can ask for this. I think. What was the first one? The first one was like, what are you fan? I grew up, my dad was more of a Star Trek fan than a Star Wars fan, but I did have a couple of Star Wars toys that we got to garage sale, so I was a fan of the movies. And to be asked to do it was, I thought about it a lot because again, I didn't want to
be bad in it. So you got an offer? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I got an offer, but there was no script to read, which I'd never done before. So you had to commit to it. JJ walked me through the whole thing, but there was no script that you could actually see how that how that played out. But also Adam, I'm sure you thought at the time, because I was certainly we had just finished working together. I was very well aware of you, your talent,
your position in the community, what your potential was, as far as jobs and fancy directors and all that stuff. I'm sure at a point, you must have thought, even though you're not a strategic thinker, you know, annoying like that. But so that, well, I don't want to sign up for something where this is going to be louder than anything I'll ever do in my career.
Am I tying myself to this for multiple films? And did any of that go through your head? I'm sure it must have a little bit. No, actually, no. I never thought that this was going to be the only job I got. I mean, I don't know why I didn't think that it was going to be, I didn't think I'd do anything bigger than that. But I hoped I was optimistic that I would work after it.
And hopefully not. I wasn't thinking that too far ahead like that of what the end result of it would be because the end result could also be you were in a movie that everybody saw and nobody liked. And they didn't like you in it and they didn't like the movie. And the idea that some, a movie of that scale
that anyone would actually watch it, I guess it was just coming from girls. And this is where I leave you and try to use it. So great. Thanks. And it was very compassionate people about it. Like Sean would be like, what is he doing in this? And he's ruining the franchise.
You don't want that. No, I would never. But it's gotta be cool to go through the process of seeing the drawings of your character than the fittings, the costume fittings, and then touching the props and all that stuff must have been touching the props. Yeah, carefully.
Don't wreck your pants, Sean. Jesus. That is so cool. By the way, you're one of the few people that I turned to Scottie and I said, I have such a massive talent crush on that guy. Yeah. You're so good in everything you do, but especially in love. I agree. And I think you know what is amazing?
And kind of also this kind of fits in Jason a little bit with what you were saying is like, you, you know, you do like these, you know, a star was one of the most, you know, I don't know if there's a bigger sort of brand in terms of film and, you know, maybe it's sort of the marvel cinema universe and all that kind of shit. But you do that and not only does it not paint you into a corner, it kind of does the opposite. It opens you up to a whole
to all these people globally and then you continue going, I said at the start when the boys were trying to guess who my guess was, if you look at the list of directors that you've worked with, it's almost peerless, man. You're in that way. It's just remarkable how many of these incredible, some of the greatest directors of our time have all asked you to come and go on these creative journeys with them, and that's gotta be, feel very, and I guess, I also noticed the way you talk about stuff,
you're not a strategic thinker. Like it seems like you are like, you just kind of go with what inspires you. Am I right about that a little bit? Well, yes and no, I'm not strategic in that. I'm like, oh, this needs to make money. So we, although I should think that way, where I do get now that you don't do movies that make money, they'll stop asking you to make movies.
That's what I've been told. But I, my mind, it's a filmmaker's medium, so I'm strategic in that. Well, isn't the goal then to work with great filmmakers? And, you know, sometimes I feel like if I connect with it, then I can, but I've people that I've wanted to work with where the thing that they wanted to do, I knew I couldn't do or I felt like I wouldn't get there. And so I'm not really answering your question.
But I am strategic in that, like, it's a filmmaker's medium, it's a, plays or a playwright's medium. TV seems to be a filmmaker's medium. It's a, you know, plays or a playwright's medium. You know, TV seems to be a writer's medium that's, you know, those are the people that I always wanted to work with. And I made myself available to try to work with them if it came up.
You've also, you've also in the last two years played two very significant portrayed, two very significant. Italian men, one, one a designer. And I'm both both incredible creative minds, if you think about what within their thing, right? You played Mauricio Gucci. Right. And now you're playing currently Enzo Ferrari. I mean, that's...
Yeah, I guess that's a good example of not being strategic in a way that I probably should. Like, I've seen so many people have been like, I'm gonna be like, I'm like, it's just kind of worked out that way. And I think someone probably would have said, like maybe because it's gonna come up a lot, you know, but I'm like, well, it's Ridley and it's Michael. And I, in my mind, some of the best filmmakers
who gives a shit that there's two Italians back to back. Exactly. Yeah, who gives a shit and also, like you said, two incredible filmmakers and two great stories. So who gives a shit what it is? You make 10 in a row probably, I imagine you would, if they were great stories and great directors. Yeah, well probably not Italians anymore though,
but yeah, because I'm surprised how much it comes up, you know, it's like, you know, are you have a thing? I'm like, it's two. There's two Italians, you know? Yeah, yeah. Two Italians. Because it's like, I'm like, oh, right, pre, pre, you know, that these things are not a place, or I mean, this is,
but press isn't a place that you have a nuanced conversation. Right. And that seems like a hard idea of like, well, what is it with Italy? Well, I mean, it's less to do with Italy, although I like it, but it's more about Ridley Scott and Michael Mann who end the projects themselves. And Italy is not the first thing on my mind. Right, Robert, you're not calling your age as going like,
hey, give me another great Italian role, they'll play. Yeah, right, right. Come parry, I hear, it's not like you're not calling your ages going like hey give me another great Italian role to play Yeah, right right here is not done That market what about what about we you into car racing at all beforehand? No, it's probably didn't I was into cars I didn't the car bike. Yeah, you know, I wasn't you know, I knew of Ferrari's mostly from Miami vice You know, yeah and take it And take it with unattainable, it just wasn't part of my upbringing, you know. Right. Well, again, Michael Mann right there.
Are you like, it's like a sports guy, you play a lot of sports, boxing, and like that. Like, I know I like watching, I'm kind of stuck in time a little bit with late 90s Michael Jordan. Right. So I'm just now only recently, because I'm trying to work less,
I've gotten back into going to basketball. But basketball is my sport. Does that make you a next fan or a pastors fan? Yeah, it makes me a next fan, because I'm in Brooklyn. A next? Yeah. Right.
Yeah. And so, so basketball is your thing, but you're not like a watch football day kind of guy, or anything like that. No, no, no, no, I wish I did. I mean, sometimes I watch football a day, but not really. I mean, I watch Tyson highlights, but like my Tyson highlights, but I won't keep up today with the, like I missed the Tyson Fury fight and I'm not a full-max Tyson. Remember Mike Tyson was just like, it was just horrific watching what he would do to people.
And I could not stop watching. We haven't had a boxer like that since him, have we? No. No, I mean, what's his name, the guy, the English guy, who's, what, you just said him? Tyson Fury. Tyson Fury, yeah. He's been fairly dominant, but not in that same way.
There's last fight, didn't he get knocked down twice to a third time? That's all UFC, right? It's all UFC. I can't, you know, I'm sure we'll have some fans who are like, you know, grow up, but I find UFC to be so dark. Oh, great. The energy is so dark for me.
I don't know. There's something about it. It seems real. I used to watch it right before I got to bed. One time in the middle of the night in my dream, I thought I was in a fight and I threw an elbow at a man-dop. And I just missed her freaking nose. Oh, I just laughed at pillow that she was sleeping on
because I was in a fight in my dream. Did you watch the UFC? Right before I went to bed, it was like a stupidest thing. It's like, am I supposed to have a big stake too? I should have done it killing somebody. I don't know. Anyway, we digress. We'll be right back.
This episode is brought to you in part by Helix. Hey guys, let me tell you about a game changer in the sleep department Helix mattresses. Now, I've had my Helix mattress for almost four years and it's been a total sleep revolution. Sleep is everything, right? It gives you energy, it gives you focus. It sets your mood for the day,
and Helix has been a help for me this whole time. It's a dawn for a new day with my dusk lux. Ugh, that was bad. I'm still waking up on my Helix mattress. Helix doesn't just offer one size fits all. With 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Luxe Collection and the Helix Elite designed for big
and tall sleepers, they've got something for everyone. Now, how do you find your perfect match? Easy. Take the Helix sleep quiz, and under two minutes, you'll know what mattress suits your body and sleep preferences. And guess what? It ships to your door, free of charge! I take the quiz and got matched with my dream mattress. Thank you so much, Helix. Helix is offering 25% up all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners through January 7th.
Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless and use code helixpartner25. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. Helixsleep.com slash smartless code helixpartner25 with helix better sleep starts now. Hey there, Smartless listener. This message comes from our cool sponsor, Naples, Marco Island and the Everglades,
Florida's Paradise Coast. Imagine chilling on 30 miles of pristine Gulf Shoreline from the secluded Keyway in Island to Swanky Beachfront Resorts. They've got a spot for everyone. Adventure junkies get ready for a wild ride through endless mangroves, estuaries, and shorelines. Boating, fishing, diving, and tons of golf,
they got it all, feeling fancy. Treat yourself to upscale boutique's art galleries and world-class spas in Naples. I mean, come on, what's more relaxing than lounging amid cipristries to the soothing sounds of golf breezes? Wearing a wheelchair in all the years. Foodies, this one's for you. Dive into a mix of flavors with fresh from the golf seafood sounds of gulf breezes. to start plotting your next adventure. One more time, that's ParadiseCoast.com slash smartless. Happy travels.
And now back to the show. Adam, are you gonna, is there any more talk about more Star Wars stuff? Like, I don't know. Oh, boy, look, he's back. Yeah, that is back. They're doing stuff, yeah, but not with me. I'm not doing it.
So you're done because of the characters stuff. Yeah. Yeah. All right. And so, and then, but not with me. I'm not doing it. So you're done because of the character stuff. Yeah. All right. And then, but wait, did you? But would you? But if you did, what character do you think? My name is...
My name is... I came to you tomorrow and... If JJ was really nice about it. No, I want to know, can you just give me one good story from filming something that was great or went wrong or something that was surprising? Or, oh, you know what, you know what, I loved. This is what I loved. When it was at the end of Forza Wacens
and you're doing the final battle with Ray. It's like he's stuck in an elevator at Comic Con. And you're fucking, it's your fucking nightmare first. I just want to say what I'm doing. I'm never gonna run into the guy, ever again. So, I hope I do. But when you're wounded, when she got you, and you're walking around in a circle,
and you start banging the side of your hip, like this, trying to get like the pain away or something, because it's bleeding. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Who's ideal? Is that such a cool, specific actor? I've never seen that. So cool. Thanks.
I will actually legit me say that was mine. That the idea that we, how it was pitched to me was, again, none of these were written, but that very beginning was that his journey was supposed to be the opposite ofators in that he starts almost the most, as opposed to someone who's the most dark from the beginning and then by the end of the series becomes the most vulnerable that he starts almost the most, as opposed to someone who's the most dark from the beginning, and then by the end of the series becomes the most vulnerable, that he starts the most vulnerable and becomes little by little more committed to the dark side. I feel like eventually they, they, I think, got rid of that idea, but in my mind as I was playing it, that's what I was working towards. So all of this stuff is anytime that even abstractly that by the end of the movie it starts anything that starts to come
into his world, there are minds in that he's vulnerable, he has to get rid of it. So, I think just in the abstract way it was. Okay, so then when you got wounded and you were bleeding, you're like, I got to get rid of this. Like, yeah, yeah, yeah. It wasn't very conscious. I wasn't consciously thinking of it. I think that that's just like this pain. He's trying to snuff out anything. He's getting more and more. So by the time we're after he kills Han, you know, hopefully that you see in his face that he shifts into, you know, he's made a choice that he's going to commit to the dark side. Yeah, yeah. How does he like the pace of that, you know, it's all all the effects and stunts and things like that? I would imagine because of their luxury of schedule too, that you didn't have to shoot a lot of pages every day.
You, I just remember working with you that you'd like to keep a nice momentum going. You, you stay in it and you're ready. How are you able to throttle up and throttle back with the slow pace? There's a massive adjustment. Even when this is where I leave you, I hadn't quite figured out where to be economical at all. So the breaks in between, I'd never figured out the language of a film set. So I was still figuring it out.
So I was wasting just like a lot of energy trying to keep something like kind of an engine going. That was, I made Star Wars was way more exhausting for me than I, I made it more exhausting than it should have been. Because I had quite a bit of the momentum of a set that was that big before. All the things that worked on were really small and they moved pretty fast.
So what did you learn? I love that idea. Yeah, I remember somebody saying, I never say to somebody like, coming off rest of them and then doing a couple of moves and I was like, fuck, make it a movie, so boring. And because it was just take so fucking long
and you have all this big time in between. And like, how do you stay in, especially making a comedy? You're like, it's so hard to make a good comedy movie because there's just, it's so hard to make a good comedy movie because there's just no momentum. Momentum. And you need that to keep it up, right? And so what did you do actively to kind of train yourself
to perform in films that was different? Did you have something like a technique? Yeah, well, usually the director sets the pace of the set. I don't like to be the person that tries to control the pace or rhythm of the set. I kind of let the person that's to, you know, they kind of, and so I have to adjust, like Spike Lee and Soderberg shoot really fast.
And for me, that's not comfortable, but it's their movie and their film. So I adjust to what it is that they're doing. So things like that, I won't go back to the trailer, I'll stay on set mostly, and then if I need to escape, you know, a conversation, you know, a side conversation, then I will just to try to stay focused if you know, for questions about Star Wars or something. Yeah, some fucking boober nerds. Yeah, you're trying to get into being in zofrari and you got one more thing.
When they were on planet, Volt-Hand, was it true that the Caribbean sun burned their helmets off? Sean of all the characters at all the Star Wars universe, what character do you think you would have liked to have played the most? Me? Yeah, you three PO. Luke Skywalker, of course. Yeah. Huh. Luke Skywalker. Yeah, of course. Well, with a lower octave, maybe. What's that? What's that? Paul? Yeah. We want to go, something about the Tashi station. We wanted to go back to the Tashi station or something. Mark Hamill says, it's really whining.
It's such a funny line. Everybody makes fun of it now, but it's so, it was so great. Oh, right. Yeah. You know, I'm talking about, I wanted to go back in the town to pick up some power converters in the Tashi station. I remember. That's the first one, right?
That's the first one. And last, we're done with the Star Wars. But are you so happy to not have to talk about it at length? I know we did a little bit here, but are you like, you try to avoid, like, you know, do you try to focus on moving forward? No, I don't, honestly, not a lot of people talk to me about it. When they do, they mostly ask me,
even when you're asking is different than when most people ask me. So, and the only thing about it when they do, they mostly ask me. Even what you're asking is different than what most people ask me. And the only thing about it is I would talk at length often about some movie that you're trying to support. And then you say one thing about Star Wars. And that becomes the thing there, Michael. Right. Yeah, that first was the point of it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Do you miss shooting a series in Brooklyn? I do. I do, I do. Right? Do you really think you'd love that? Yeah, well, because I'd be Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Do you miss shooting a series in Brooklyn? I do, I do, I do, I do. Right? Do you really? I love that. Yeah, well, because I'd be close to home and like,
yeah, I didn't realize how luxurious that was. Wait, you said this already, where are you from originally? Indiana. Indiana. Oh, look who just joined the podcast. You said it. We talked about it a few times.
He was in a blackout trying to form a Star Wars question. You know most people, when they talk in the conversation, they don't spend all their time thinking about what I'm going to say when other people are talking. Just listen. I don't know how the conversation happens. So what's your feeling about? I think it's fascinating when people... Would you ever move to Indiana? Yeah. You would never live in Los Angeles. It's not just not your speed. No, he did. No, yeah, no, I know. It's not my, I enjoy the four seasons. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I get it, I get it.
Yeah, mine. God, that's been coming up so much lately with us about LA and New York, right? JB, we were talking about the other night. Yeah. And I lived in New York for over 20 years. And when I left, when my kids, when my older kids were little, I moved to LA and I was like, I don't know if I ever wanna move to New York.
And now these days, more and more, I'm like, I've been dying to live back in New York. 16. I mean, I would love. Why'd you say? I would just love to, because of the seasons, because of the, there's so many different industries that are centered there.
So the people you talk to have something to say about so many things you know nothing about. Yeah, it's not a company town, like L.A. It's such a company town. Right, right, right. It is boring though. In that way, we always say that, like if all your references are just about this,
then you know, what you're working on. Yeah, that's what I feel when I come here, but I didn references are just about this, then you know. What's your workin' on? Yeah, that's what I feel when I come here, but I didn't think I was like, maybe I'm just, because every time I come, it's for something that is related to that too. I'm like, well, I've actually never spent time here, so I can't really say that, but it feels that way. It feels like, with New York,
there's just so much other shit goin' on that is nothing to do with that. It's stimulating, you know? It is. Everybody's workin' doin' somethin' that you don't know anything it. It's stimulating. You know? It is. Everybody's working doing something that you don't know anything about. It's very interesting. Which, if you can, it's also nice to get out of the city
if you can't, because you can just be sitting in your apartment and feel the energy of the place outside and feel like you need to be doing something, which is also like can be exhausting. But I know I love New York. No, they all always. Yeah, hopefully. Yeah.
Yeah, that's how I just put your glasses. Yeah, I have a question for all three of you with you all three of them. Yeah, I would too. Hopefully. Yeah. Yeah, sorry. Put your glasses on. Yeah, I have a question for all three of you. You all three up kids. When you take your kid to a school for the first time, it's gotta be like, I want to deal with the... I have to meet everybody. How are you?
And then they are asking to ask you dumb questions. Like, I'm asking you Adam, dumb questions, or whatever, you're gonna find yourself trapped by teachers or other parents or whatever. How do you deal with all that? Because you're a known person. Yeah, you're in the public eye. I, when my son was born, when he was in, before he was in school,
I didn't really go outside with him much because I didn't want people to bother him. And then the one time I went out with him in Italy, immediately, you know, we were like, oh, it's the pandemic. Like clearly no one's following us and boom, they got us and people took pictures of my kid. But then it was kind of like to point where I should go outside with I'm missing out on all this shit.
So do you get hassled? Do you get hounded a lot by paparazzi and stuff like that? Not paparazzi necessarily, but people. And it's all good. It's fine, but after, when you're with your kid and you're trying to do something, then now he's at the age where he's starting to track like put it together.
Yeah, yeah. So what does it look like for you? I mean, I do want to ask you a little bit about, um, about Ferrari. Cause you, you know, I'm sorry, but we're with, I can't wait to see it. I know. Working with Michael, man, obviously, what was that process like for you? Cause I mean, it was pretty on-composing, I imagine. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was prosthetics that we didn't realize we're going to be as involved. We had no money. Well, I mean, we had money, but we had not a lot of money for how Michael wanted to do it and not a lot of time.
So it was very, you know, 17-hour days, sometimes a couple of times, 20-hour days. And in Modena, you know, where everything was happening, where everything happened for Enzo. It's like the barber shop he went to, the same, the grandson of the guy who actually was his barber, the actual factory, the place where the crash was, everything is very meticulous and authentic and incredibly thoroughly researched and, you know, going to the factory and seeing the engines, shipping in the actual, some of the actual cars that won the Mielemea, some of these $70 million for Aris that he would just bring there just to get the sound, and hook up nine mics to them and but at the same time, he's very researched, but is after something pretty abstract. He's famously well researched and very
meticulous about clothes and sound and all of the details. But then is very good about making shit up in the moment. Well, you mentioned, maybe, vice. I was a huge, maybe vice fan of the show. Oh, God, you have the show. Yeah, because I was a young teen when that show was like that. Dude, when DJ Don Johnson knows this, I've told him he knows this. When he shaved his head that like third season or whatever went to a buzz cut, I did it. That's how I do it I was. I thought it was so fucking cool. I'd never seen anything like it. And part of it was, A. Don is great.
It was so cool. But the way that Michael Mann understood the making of the film, the balance of, you know, really, you know, cool setups, really cool shots. He, you know, really making the most of it, setting the tone that he was able to set. And with the music, he was the first guy who made like really cool mod, like it was almost like a lot of those shows were almost like music videos in the middle that had these incredible montages. And yeah, it was just breathtaking to watch him, you know, do all that shit.
There's that really famous one where they have in the air tonight with Phil Collins that whole sequence. The camera set up on the side of the car, you're watching the wheel and then it's going down the thing and then it's the reflection off the hood and then he goes to that phone booth that's miraculously at the end of a pier all by itself.
That calls as X-Wife. Clause as X-Wife, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, all by itself. That's right. Causes ex-wife. Causes ex-wife, yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah, great shit. And you watch that. I mean, that was like 1984, man. And like just elevated shit. Yeah, he's very into rewatching his movies now. He's obsessed with internal life.
He really believes in it that's cinematic and interesting enough. Then when I watch, like last in Mohicans or he Or the last in Mohicans in particular. They don't have a lot of screen time to really fall in love But because they're you can tell they're so you know Field you know internally you totally buy it and he's really into that all of his notes are about internal stuff He's really rare in that way Not a lot of directors really talk about internal issues.
No, shit. And then he trusts that the audience can kind of read your mind a little bit. If you're really cooking inside, you don't need to say it. They'll lean forward and try to read you. And is that, and is that about staging in the way that he shoots it, that, that to him in order to kind of reveal, to get into that interliving? Yeah, yeah. He's all about yeah. All of his choices are about, there's this thing where he's obsessed with ties.
There's a lot of famous stories about him. Like, you know, someone will say an offhanded comment and I'm like, oh, that's a nice tie. He's like, what'd you say? And they're like, oh, he's just saying that he had a nice tie. He's like, okay, we gotta go find another tie. And I'll spend two hours finding the right tie.
And then you ask him, he's like, well, if you're looking at the tie then you're not looking at the actress face. And I want you to be like engrossed in what's going on in the, he's like the blacks in the scene are right. They need to be 50% like darker, because then you can really get into the pupils, you know? It's all about like internal life.
He wants to see, which I think is, you know, that's what makes those movies rewatchable and timeless as he there's a lot of respect that people will get it, you know, which fucking yeah, it's also got this, he's also got this, he's got a like a Michael man three quarter shot of this like a handheld that's right behind the actor's ear and it just kind of creeps around a little bit and exposes just one of the eyes and it gets you inside an actor's head like he a character's head. He uses that quite a bit. I love that. Yeah, I don't know if there's a camera invented yet that would be able to reveal any interlife
on Jason. I don't know. No, just like a fuck like just fucking dad like a dial tone inside. I think you think of like you hear like a wind, like wind going through an old outhouse out in the middle of the desert. That's the sound. Yeah, that's a fall asleep earlyzy. You know, you talked about, you talked about, you talked about driving about fries and stuff so you get the drive.
So had you ever driven a Ferrari before? No, no, no, no. Never driven a Ferrari. Do you have one now? No, no, no. Do you want one now? Would you ever get one? If it gave me one, sure, yeah. Are you like a motorcycle guy at all?
I, yeah, I have a couple motorcycles. You do, of course you do. You got children now, I know. I know, I know, but. Yeah, let's get rid of those. Do you guys know this that I had a Ferrari for a few years? Is that right? Yeah, I had a Ferrari.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Is that what you fucking buy you one? It's a long story, but I had that they did. But I had a Ferrari. I was gifted a Ferrari, but it was was one of those old, you know, a Ferrari, the 412. It kind of, it kind of looks like a coupe. Do you remember that car? And it's in the beginning of Rainman, Tom Cruise is driving that when he's going out to Palm Springs and he gets the phone call and he's got a turnaround with the, with the windmills
in behind. It's a beautiful, beautiful car. You wanted to be Don Johnson and Tom. So you went ahead and you sold that, you sold that Ferrari, the gift to you and you turned a little profit I guess, huh? I ended up selling it because, you know why? Because if you didn't drive it all the time,
it would sit there and you would constantly have to like, repair shit and that was just the way it was. And I think- What a relatable story. So you just pocketed, what'd you get about 150 grand for it or something like that? No, because I paid so much to keep it. A lot of taxes. It's been such a pleasure. It does seem relatable though.
No, by the way, I've known you're mean. Wait, when does Ferrari come out? Christmas day. Christmas time. Christmas time. Just in time. Okay, like a gift from, like a gift from Jesus. Yeah, himself. Adam, I could just ask you, man, I just, I'm just fascinated with him, such a fan
and what you've done, man, and I'm just so happy for you, dude, and you do seem like such a genuinely good guy in, in, in, honestly. Big talent crush, like I said. Yeah, big talent. And you know what, like Jason said, I wanted to say this before, and Jason said, like I said. Yeah, big talent. And you know what Jason said, I wanted to say this before,
and Jason said when people run into you, it's not like you're just like some, there's a difference between being a celebrity and being an actor, and you're such an actor. And I mean, that is such a compliment. You're such an artist, hate using that term, but it's true to you, man. And anyway, I just wanted to say that.
I just think that you're... That means a lot. Yeah, man. Thank you a lot. Yeah, man. Thank you. You are amazing, man. I'm so glad that you joined us today. Thank you for doing this. Yeah, no, thank you for having me.
Yeah, thanks, buddy. Yeah. I'll look you up when I get to Brooklyn. And we'll ask you. He's good, man. He's got a lot of money. He's super good. You're going to love it.
Yeah. Thanks Adam, such a pleasant meeting. Adam Driver, thanks, buddy. Thanks for taking my time. All right. Thank you. Thanks for having me. All right. All right. See you.
Bye. Wow. Right? Yeah. JB, I knew you knew him. Yeah, I'm surprised. What didn't come up was some sort of tie into his last name and the Ferrari movie. Right, who's going to do that?
One of these critics are going to do it, right? Somebody writing a review or something. The driver really drives this driving movie. Who's going to do that? One of these critics are going to do it, right? Somebody writing a review or something. The driver really drives this driving movie, huh? Something like that. I can go ahead. Yeah, well, if they're going to do it, it'll be probably a little bit short. Probably something like that. Yeah. Well, you know, the whole time, anytime you said that word, it was something like that. No, it's something like that. He's really cool. It's wild to meet him. It's really cool. That's how he is.
He is a very, very good dude. Yeah. Yeah. He just, he seems very sort of like he's got like a generous spirit. Like you said, he's an actor. He's an actor. He's an actor. Oh, yeah, he's an actor.
He's, yeah, he's so calm. He's, yeah, he's excited to have him. He's going to be, he's going to be with us for a long time. He's going to be like, yeah, great actors until we're old and gray. Yeah, for sure. And I just, I don't know. There's something about, I love the fact that, and I know, I don't feel like it did a good job of getting into it of like this.
The way that he just kept, he applied to July 2017, didn't get in, but then he went into the military, but then he came back to it. And he went, like, he was like, he went to LA and then, it broke down and he fucking went home, but he came back to it. Like he just, he was not going to be, this is what he wanted to do. And he knew he had a gift for it. You don't stop, do you get it? You don't stop.
He's a serious person that also it's got a great sense of humor. It's not really funny. It's really funny. It's really, really funny. I didn't know, I didn't know, first of all, I didn't know he went, it was in the Marine Corps. And that's why I asked him like, First of all, didn't know he went in the Marine Corps. And that's why that's why I asked him like where he did like a Ted talk where he talked about it.
I saw that. Oh, really? I don't follow all the Ted talks. Yeah. It's it's it's really. You're not up in your. I'm sure he's not the only actor that's been a Marine, but you don't hear about it a lot.
I mean, you know, that's a lot of. The whole time he was there. That's why I asked him if he was thinking about acting. What's that? Rob Riggle. Rob Riggle. Yeah, I knew. But yeah, you don't hear about a lot.
So you didn't know he was in the Marines and what else he was in the Marines. And I like what he said about Michael Mann too about, you know, you always buy into it and everything, everything that he, Adam does, I think. Oh, I thought he just parted by your buy. Right there. You said that Adam plays. You also buy into it.
No, no, no, no. Will you guys think? I was going to say, less sloppy and just like easy way out, like you, like as if you're late for a bus. I'm gonna say hearing what he said, those were really words to live. Bye! Bye! Acceptable.
We will allow, bye. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unjurf.
If you like Smartless, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wundri Plus in the Wundri app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen to add free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wundri.com Slash Survey. What if your partner developed 21 new identities? Or you discovered that your friend who helped you through the darkest times was actually a conniving con artist?
Or what if you began seeing demons everywhere, inhabiting people around you, including your son? What would you do? I'm Whit Missildine, the creator of this is actually happening, a podcast that brings you extraordinary true stories of life-changing events, told by the people who lived them. In our newest season, you'll hear even more intimate first-person accounts of how regular people have overcome remarkable circumstances, like the man who went to jail for 17 years
for accidentally shooting the person who tried to save his life, to a close friend of the infamous scam artist Amanda Riley. These haunting accounts sound like Hollywood movies, but I assure you, this is actually happening. Follow this is actually happening on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts, and you can listen to this is actually happening ad-free on Wondry Plus. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.